An evaluation metric that doesn't have this shortcoming is called r squared, and
is a very popular evaluation metric for
describing the goodness of fit of a linear regression.
And, what r squared is, is it's a number that effectively answers the question,
how much of my change in the output is explained by the change in my input?
And, the values that r squared can take on, will be between 0 and 1.
If the number is very small, that generally means that
your regression line isn't doing a good job of capturing the trend in the data.
On the other hand, if r squared is large, close to 1, what that means is
your regression line is doing a good job of describing the relationship
between your input, or your x variable, and your output, or your y variable.
And, remember, this is the whole point of performing a regression,
is to come up with a mathematical formula that describes this relationship.
So, if your r square is close to 1,
it basically means your fit is doing a good job.
The good thing about r squared,
is that it's independent of the number of training points.
So, it'll always be between 0 and 1.
In general, it's not affected by the number of points in your data set.
So, this is a little bit more reliable than a sum of squared errors.
Especially, if the number of points in the data set could
potentially be changing.